there's a lot of people on the American
right today who romanticized the
Constitution and the founding fathers as
unified and conservative when it comes
to their mindset in terms of the
creation of the United States of America
and if not conservative at least
classically liberal as has become
popular to say recently but before we
even analyze that I think it's important
to really be clear that this kind of
dogmatic reverence towards the
Constitution is pretty counterproductive
because the mindset of a bunch of dudes
more than 200 years ago just doesn't
give us the answers that we need to
complicated questions about society
today yeah we need a system of laws
which can only be changed through
established processes that's why
countries have constitutions but the
Constitution is not infallible the
founders weren't perfect the laws that
were written in the 18th century aren't
all going to be relevant to us forever
but if the right-wingers want to insist
on projecting their ideology onto the
founding fathers and they want to accuse
progressives of being the opposite of
what the Constitution espouses as values
or what the founders espoused as values
or what is American political tradition
we kind of have no choice but to point
out that the founding fathers and their
ideology were progressive not
conservative progressive was first used
to describe a turn of the 20th century
movement that wanted government to
reduce wealth inequality reduce the
negative byproducts of industrialization
and of capitalism but those principles
weren't new at the time and they're
still espoused by the left today so for
our purposes when I talk about
progressive I mean left to Center left
value system that's compatible with
capitalism it allows for private
property but it prioritizes equality and
public safety and public health and it
sees government as a tool to maintain
that situation that philosophy is a
primary theme in much of what was said
and done by the founding fathers they
were progressive
I think there's no question about it
let's start with health care okay in
1798 Congress passed a law signed by
then-president founding father John
Adams which established a government-run
health care program mandating that
privately employed sailors buy health
insurance
it required ship owners and sailors to
each contribute about one percent of the
sailors wages and most of the medical
treatment was administered at hospitals
that were owned and operated by the
government there was recently a debate
about whether Obama's health care
mandate was constitutional the people
who wrote this law in 1798 didn't need
to speculate about whether the law was
compatible with the idea of the
Constitution's framers because many of
the members of that Congress were also
drafters of the Constitution the
founding fathers involved with this bill
supported government health care
government health care facilities and
mandatory taxes to pay for it period
these were the founding fathers so now
let's talk more about taxes because that
connects to the health care issue
constitutional conservatives
constitutional fetishists call them
whatever you want they might not like it
but Thomas Paine was an open advocate
for a progressive income tax
James Madison signed into law a
progressive estate tax in 1797 Thomas
Jefferson prominently supported
progressive taxation in a 1785 letter to
James Madison he said quote the
consequences of this enormous inequality
producing so much misery to the bulk of
mankind legislators cannot invent too
many devices for subdividing property
another means of silently lessening the
inequality of property is to exempt all
from taxation below a certain point and
to tax the higher portions of property
in geometrical progression as they rise
it is not too soon to provide by every
possible means that as few as possible
shall be without a little portion of
land modern debates about
gun rights are definitely one of the
most common places where we hear from
the right about how the founding fathers
supposedly intended things to be and how
liberals today want the opposite when
the Second Amendment was adopted most
states had laws against traveling with a
gun or concealing a gun and the Second
Amendment didn't affect this it wasn't
until much later that the Second
Amendment was interpreted to guarantee
the right to carry a gun in public when
the United States was created there was
nothing like Stand Your Ground laws that
exist in some parts of the country today
in the early days one had a duty to
retreat when in danger deadly force was
justified only if you were in your home
and had no other alternative to protect
yourself the Stand Your Ground laws that
we see today only started to appear
about a hundred years after the adoption
of the Second Amendment
there was actually a 1786 law here in
Boston that regulated how people were
allowed to store their guns requiring
them to be unloaded which apparently
didn't conflict with the founders
conception of the Second Amendment so
gun regulation has always existed in the
United States many of the rights that
conservatives claim come from the Second
Amendment weren't even rights at all
when the Second Amendment took effect
gun rights advocates later reinterpreted
the Constitution to serve their purposes
contrary to the original intent of the
founders which is what they always
accuse the left of doing it's actually
complete and utter projection on their
behalf many of the founding fathers were
also progressive when it comes to
immigration and pluralism if you look at
his 1791 book report on manufactures
Alexander Hamilton wrote quote
immigrants exhibit a large proportion of
ingenious and valuable workmen who by
expatriated improved their own condition
and added to the industry and wealth of
the United States in Thomas Paine's book
Rights of Man he wrote quote if there is
a country in the world where conquered
according to common calculation would be
least expected it is America made up
is of people from different nations
accustomed to different forms and habits
of government speaking different
languages and more different in their
modes of worship it would appear that
the union of such a people would be
impracticable but by the simple
operation of constructing government on
the principles of society and the rights
of men every difficulty retires and all
the parts are brought into cordial
unison there the poor are not oppressed
the rich are not privileged James
Madison wrote in 1790 freedom of
emigration is due to the general
interests of humanity the course of
emigrations being always from places
where living is more difficult to places
where it is less difficult the happiness
of the emigrant is promoted by the
change and as a more numerous progeny is
another effect of the same cause human
life is at once made a greater blessing
and more individuals are created to
partake of it we often hear from today's
Christian conservatives that all the
founding fathers were Christians and
that America was intended to be a
Christian nation neither is true and the
United States Constitution was actually
designed by the founders to explicitly
isolate government from religion and to
maintain equality across different
religious beliefs or even non belief or
absence of belief in religion to be
clear whether any particular founder was
Christian isn't necessarily a matter of
whether they were progressive or
left-wing or right-wing but to deal with
today's right-wing argument that
Christianity and God should influence
American lawmaking
because the founders were Christian we
have to deal with that first assumption
that the founders were as a whole
Christian because they were not first of
all we shouldn't even care what the
private religious beliefs of the
founding fathers may have been it might
be important if you're writing a
biography about them but if we're
talking about the country's founding
itself all that matters are the
political and legal philosophies that
the founders upheld the founding didn't
require a particular religion the
precursor to the American
revolution was the enlightenment and
other historical revolutions and legal
documents if all of the founders were a
Christian it would be because everyone
in the West was Christian during that
time period and their Christianity was a
coincidence to their political
philosophies that they held but this is
really important the founders were not
all Christian
there were many religious skeptics
during that period which subscribed to a
philosophy called deism which unlike
Christianity says that God does not
interfere with the physical world or
cause supernatural events there's
evidence that central founding fathers
like Thomas Jefferson Thomas Paine James
Madison Benjamin Franklin were deists
not Christians in a letter to John Adams
Thomas Jefferson actually wrote quote
the day will come when the mystical
generation of Jesus by the Supreme Being
in the womb of a virgin
will be classed with the fable of the
generation of Minerva in the brain of
Jupiter the Declaration of Independence
says nothing about God having a role in
government or giving power to government
the document conveys that government's
power should come only from the people
that it governs the word God doesn't
appear anywhere in the US Constitution
and the only references to religion in
the Constitution are actually to limit
religions influence on the government
the First Amendment as many of you know
guarantees that quote Congress shall
make no law respecting an establishment
of religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof and Thomas Jefferson
said that this clause quote builds a
wall of separation between church and
state article 6 of the Constitution says
no religious test shall ever be required
as a qualification to any office or
public trust under the United States the
Federalist Papers may be our best guide
to the intentions of the Constitution
never mentions God or religion except to
say that it has no role in government
James Madison known as the father of the
Constitution wrote in 1774
quote religious bondage shackles and
debilitates the mind and unfit sit for
every noble enterprise if you look at
article 11 of the Treaty of Tripoli
signed by John Adams it says quote the
government of the United States of
America is not in any sense founded on
the Christian religion
now many will claim that the slogan In
God We Trust came from the founding this
is wrong wasn't associated with any
American symbols until it appeared on
coins in 1864 and it didn't become an
official u.s. motto until 1956 under God
wasn't even added to the Pledge of
Allegiance until 1954 we see a lot of
overlap between American symbols and
religion and many people think that this
was the doing of the founders but it
didn't happen until a lot later a lot of
it in the 1950s and it was caused by
deeply religious Dwight Eisenhower and
the socially conservative sort of
zeitgeist of the time the founders
progressively made it a point to protect
minority religious views as long as
people on the right today want to play
this game that the they claim that the
founding fathers were unified in an
ideology that matches modern
conservatism we have to tell them they
were wrong and we have to defend it with
evidence the founders were progressive
much of what they said and wrote and
enacted into law runs parallel to
today's left-of-center values and
policies they were progressive in that
they were forward-thinking and they were
subversive the progressive movement that
started at the turn of the 20th century
was a further realization of the values
of the founders including the idea that
the privileged shouldn't prosper at the
expense of common people this was
expressed by the founders deciding to
separate from Britain and establish a
government meant to empower common
people not just a powerful overclass the
creation of America as it took place was
in and of itself an extraordinarily
progressive act progressivism was
expressed in the founders agreement to
abolish
the first constitution of America called
the Articles of Confederation an update
and reinvent it into something that they
deemed was sort of more useful in a new
era instead of treating those Articles
of Confederation as something divine and
eternally perfect we should apply the
same logic to the Constitution today not
to mention that they replace the
Articles of Confederation with something
far more progressive Constitution that
in contrast to those first Articles of
Confederation provided a strong central
government and a court system federal
taxes federal trade regulations
legislative representation based on
population loser requirements for
adopting new laws in the future and
amending the Constitution so not only
were our founders progressive in
reimagining our country's fundamental
framework into something more practical
they actually reimagined it into
something that was far to the left of
the decentralized libertarian mess that
existed before but now let's circle back
to the very beginning after everything
I've told you about the founding fathers
being progressive we actually shouldn't
care so much about the intent of
politicians from the 18th century anyway
because it's 2019 when conservatives
today tell us that the text of the
Constitution and the intent of the
framers are all we need to deal with
today's problems in a society that would
be unrecognizable to someone that lived
200 years ago it doesn't make any sense
whatsoever but as long as conservatives
attempt to claim the founders as being
exclusively a part of their own
ideological tradition I'd like to point
out that it's just as easy if not easier
to argue that progressivism was a
prominent theme during the founding of
the United States and then to argue that
a 200 year old document simply cannot
tell us how to solve today's problems
disagree with me I definitely want to
hear from you